[Musique] je
ne sais pas si l'un d'entre vous est là, je
ne sais pas si l'un d'entre vous écoute,
mais si vous restez là, nous
venons pour vous, nous faisons cela depuis
un moment, nous aidons les gens et  nous n'avons pas
eu beaucoup de chance, vous n'avez aucune idée que
vous avez eu ça, faites-vous
confiance, vous n'avez pas à avoir
peur et donc les gens disent toujours que quand il y
a quelque chose à craindre
[Musique] s'il vous plaît,
vous pouvez'  Je ne reste pas ici pour de l'argent
Wow
[Musique]
pouvons-nous juste reprendre notre souffle,
savoir où j'ai un caractère distinctif en l'
entendant maintenant en voyant mon visage pour avoir
déménagé chez vous, je serai peut-être enclin à appuyer
instantanément sur la gâchette, peut-être
involontairement Pablo étant en état de
légitime défense  alors pouvons-nous juste
respirer avant de commencer tu parles encore
trop Victor il n'y a aucun moyen de vraiment te
protéger tu ne peux pas utiliser une arme
entre toi et perdre des gens et tu
ne peux même pas fuir le bébé que je
dis  vous ça parce que j'ai essayé
oh il comment il ouvre la porte aux
gens
la possibilité
[Musique]
de blesser
cela arrivera
[Musique]
pourrai-je jouer de l'accordéon tu
joues de l'accordéon
mr.  c'est vraiment de la merde en mode paella aujourd'hui Jimbo
ce n'est pas censé être facile
dix, prends juste un walkie et dis que nous
voulons aider et ça devrait être
difficile peut-être que c'est comme ça que nous savons que nous sommes sur
la bonne voie
comprends le truc peut-être que nous avons tout
le  chance dans ce monde
[Musique]
ma mère a fait tellement de choses pour s'assurer que nous
étions là
[Musique]
Morgan Dwight,
vous ne vous connaissez pas
[Musique]